there's eight games today so there's one
early game kicking off in 15 minutes qpr
norwich uh then six games at three
o'clock and then one late game a half
five so yeah it'll get busy around three
o'clock we are the content and customer
service team so we will provide all the
stats for our twitter feeds for our
clients editorially we'll be doing
features packs for tv companies sending
everything out to newspapers
whereas the guys in the other room in
the operations team they'll be recording
all the data and they will be
sort of handling everything that goes on
behind the scenes we can't plan what's
going to happen we know
sort of we have a set routine of things
we need to have a list of everything we
need to do but i mean football's
unpredictable you can never tell what's
going to happen
oh
so this is our analysis room at the
moment they're analyzing the game live
we have
a guy for each team and a checker so
if anyone uh has any sort of questions
about the data they're putting in
they'll flag it up and then the check
can check by just going back and
replaying the footage and then
re-inputting the data on certain games
we record
about 1 800 actions a game so
i mean around 900 a team obviously it's
gonna be a lot more if you're analyzing
barcelona than you are stoke or qpr or
norwich we have about 200 applications
every summer for operations guys
maybe four or five will get through to
the final uh section where they'll be
trained up i mean hand-eye coordination
has to be amazing i can do this myself
i'm too slow um but
these guys i mean a few of them been
here for a few years so they've built up
a great skill set to be able to do this
i definitely could not do it i know that
for the the hand-eye coordination they
have so it's a pretty intense you know
you've got to be doing it it's live
you've got 45 minutes they you know
they've got a little bit of time to go
back and check errors during the breaks
and we obviously go through every match
after after it's happened but while
they're doing it it's pretty intense 45
50 minutes at a time where you don't
have much led up and it's a pretty
impressive demonstration of skills i'm
not sure what skills and how they've
built them up but it's is more than i
can do certainly it takes a unique kind
of person i mean if you're good at
computer games it helps and if you have
to have a really really good knowledge
of football as well so
the speed at which everything happens
you have to be able to tell which
players which at the sort of blink of an
eye so if someone's wearing yellow boots
you might be able to say that means
that's that player and sometimes me man
united have uh
raphael and fabio two twins in the team
so
you gotta know the characteristics of
each player as well and despite they
both found different wings if something
was to come into the box you might need
a sort of to know if one wears white
boots one has tape rounded socks or
something like that so yeah you can pick
that up a lot of its communication if
one of them has a question
he might say can you double check
a defender may have made a clearance but
it might have been a long ball instead
so they'd ask the checker to just check
that replay and then if it needs
correcting correctly straight away i'll
say here we can replay the data and they
can double check
and pause and see
so quite often if there's a deflection
on a goal and we're not sure if it's an
own goal
we can then slow it down replay it pause
it so we can take different angles and
have a look at whether it is an own goal
or not
luckily the early game today is a dull
affair between qfr and nourish i say
that now and when you film again at 90
minutes or before all but yeah there's
not much going on at the moment until
something big happens maybe a goal red
card penalty we're liaising with
commentators for the game um across the
world providing them with facts and data
so yeah just waiting for something big
to happen and then we can uh get down
and do our job how common is it that you
will
pull together some fact or amazing piece
of trivia send it off from your computer
and then you hear it come across on the
tv a minute or two later yeah quite
often i mean there was a famous one in
the world cup a few years ago when rob
green disastrously let clint dempsey
shot for his hands uh against the usa
and uh straight away we our team were on
to it and uh we
remembered that he'd cr he'd actually
made the most mistakes leading to goals
in the premier league that season as
well oh it was itv mentioned it we were
being told a lot to joe that across the
world commentators were mentioning our
fact that was on up to joe so that was a
really nice moment for us and then yeah
you quite often i think mark's doing the
uh
commentator support at the moment you'll
hit you'll hear something that he's just
put across them within 30 seconds
so that's as quick as it can happen so
say if now there's a red card we could
research a fact about that red card say
it might be the player's eighth rig card
only two players have got more or
they're the team with the most red cards
this season we can put that straight to
the commentator
and then they can have that out and
mention it on screen within a minute so
i mean while the action's fresh and
while while the stat is fresh they'll
have it out there so the commentator
sounds so knowledgeable when they do
that does that does that frustrate you
and make you think you didn't know that
that was because of me
in fairness the commentators do a lot of
research before the game we're helping
them out that's our job
qpr just won a penalty knowledge you're
giving it away so i can have a quick
look now to uh see sort of how many
penalties have been given this season
for each side
using our database
right
so we can have a quick look now to see
um
noise's record this season using running
a report
this season
qpr
have won two penalties both of them have
been against norwich
home and away and they've had both of
them saved up i've now had the last
three penalties in a row saved so i'll
put that straight through now to this
guys
decision to retain a player or sign a
player is
i mean it's literally a multi-million
pound
or euro or dollar or whatever it's a
multi-million
something investment i can't imagine
many other walks of of life many other
businesses where you would just take
that based on kind of someone's feel and
intuition and you'd have someone sitting
there watching them do their job it
doesn't make sense you'd normally it's
you'd normally have numbers some way of
quantifying that the game's ended a poor
draw not the best for our uh analysis
there's not too much to talk about so
we're trying to put together some
post-match facts now qpr are now five
unbeaten in the premier league which is
their best run in the premier league
since march 95. a nice little one about
harry redknapp that he's drawn more
games neil neal than any other manager
in the premier league 62nd that was what
we do now is we put together the
post-match facts
save all the stats for the game send
them out to the media
um and then
sort of just
wait for the three o'clock games and the
fun to start
i'd say it's been
an above average day for action and
there's quite a lot going on as there's
six games at the moment lucas podolski's
just scored for arsenal so
but it seems to be this allowed
but um yeah i mean it's been pretty
hectic i mean there's a flurry of goals
around the midway point of the first
half so
yeah it's been right there's plenty of
stuff sort of coming out today so yeah
you